joke camp is an animal coordinator for
film and television in Los Angeles
Lauren Williams and Bryan Hill are
professional dog trainers with eight
years of experience teaching dogs to
guard against intruders and attack on
command just how does the physiology of
a predator determine the manner and
power of its attack the four varieties
of dogs in this show answer that
question the bulldog makes his bite and
then uses his body not only to wrestle
the animal to the ground she's actually
twisting his bite to cause more pain the
Mastiff totally
uses nothing but its weight its attack
was head-on slam into with his body get
a grip and down you go the Malinois
and the Dutch Shepherd are very similar
in shape they draw the comparison
between the ancient gray wolf and its
larger cousin the direwolf the Malinois
being a lighter God uses the momentum or
its speed and coordination to pull its
prey down
I think the Dutch Shepherd combined all
the best traits of all the different
styles he hurled himself there for
getting momentum he opened his mouth as
wide as he could similar to the Malinois
got that good solid bite his weight
slammed into the prey just like the
bigger dogs very similar to the modern
wolf and probably the dire wolf to the
more vigorous attack of the Dutch
Shepherd hints at the advantage the dire
wolf had over its lighter gray cousin it
may have used its more massive body to
take down larger prey besides his
superior size the dire Wolf's only other
weapon was his massive head and jaw to
determine how the size of an animal's
jaw affects the strength of his bite a
specially designed meter can be used it
will measure just how much power that
jaws could pack what we have here is a
digital bite meter and the sensor has a
gap in it when the dog bites it it
closes the gap and the readout over here
tells you how much how many pounds of
force the dog is applying each dog is
lured into biting the meter and the
force of that bite is measured quickly a
relationship between bite strength and
head size emerges for example the Dutch
Shepherds head is only slightly larger
than the Malinois yet its bite is much
stronger
good boy 95 he was a 195 I got into
Maximo 224 right now but it was up to
about 2:30 and as for the Mastiff that's
the mess whoa 550 600 that that is
that's amazing a lot more than I
expected the numbers demonstrate that a
slight increase in the size of a dog's
head can yield a significantly stronger
bite this was undoubtedly true for the
prehistoric wolves it's impossible to
assign specific numbers to the dire
Wolf's bite but it appears the dire
Wolf's larger head and jaw would have
created a much stronger bite than his
grey cousin its powerful bite together
with its robust attack style probably
allowed the dire wolf to bring down much
larger prey
you